In regenerativen energien steckt eine menge potenzial und sie können einen riesigen beitrag dazu leisten den klimawandel
zumindest noch zu verlangsamen doch immer wieder ist auch von hohen kosten der erneuerbaren
energien die rede und genau deswegen gibt es jetzt für euch den großen kosten check wie stehen die erneuerbaren
energien im vergleich da ihr habt euch das thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und ich sage danke für diesen vorschlag herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Vor einigen jahren bin ich auf einen dinosaurier ingenieur getroffen er beklagte sich ernsthaft über die subventionierung von
windkraftwerken und lobte dagegen die kernenergie die sei ja so billig naja ich erinnerte ihn an ein paar
milliardenschwere bau wo ihnen in deutschland den schnellen brüter in kalkar den kugelhaufen reaktor in hamm oder das stillgelegte
kernkraft in mülheim kärlich das steht in einem
erdbebengebiet oh man aber ist die kernkraft nicht an sich total billig war braucht ja nur total wenig brennstoff
um jahre lang energie zu erzeugen naja aber die gefahren aber kommen wir zu der
kostenbilanz fest steht der klimawandel kann wohl nur noch aufgehalten oder zumindest verlangsamt werden wenn wir möglichst schnell auf erneuerbare energien umschwenken
und die sind im gegensatz zur kernkraft nämlich ungefährlich das ist und das zu recht ein
dauerbrennerthema hier bei pixum science fiction denn die lage ist wirklich ernst denn klar ist dass
energieformen wie wind und solarenergie sehr viele vorteile haben sie sind unbegrenzt weltweit ohne langen und kostspieligen
transport verfügbar und
ölkatastrophen die verstärkung des treibhauseffektes und akw unfälle können vermieden werden aber es gibt eben auch schattenseiten
diese art der stromerzeugung
ist stark vom wetter abhängig nehmen wir nur als beispiel die
photovoltaik die herausforderungen für das stromnetz besteht darin die schwankungen abzupuffern und auszugleichen
beispielsweise in dem der strom zwischengespeichert wird oder in andere regionen in denen er gerade
benötigt wird weitergeleitet wird doch das gilt als extrem kostenintensiv
und aufwendig und schadet dem image der erneuerbaren energien enorm doch wenn man nur einmal auf die kosten schaut können
erneuerbare energien punkten denn ihr wisst alle die kosten von öl erdgas und kohle steigen rasant schließlich handelt es sich hier um
energieressourcen die endlich sind von 2003 bis 2017 ist der weltmarktpreis für kohle
beispielsweise um knapp 80 prozent gestiegen von 45 euro pro tonne auf
79 euro pro tonne der preis für rohöl
hat sich in diesem zeitraum fast verdoppelt
und dieser trend nach oben wird anhalten dagegen sinken die kosten für erneuerbare energien in den letzten 15 jahren um etwa die hälfte
logisch wenn man bedenkt dass erdwärme sonne wind wasserkraft und bioenergie
dauerhaft zur verfügung stehen und nicht irgendwann aufgebraucht sind
bis 2020 sollen die kosten für erneuerbare energien um 40 prozent gesenkt werden so das ziel der branche
und ein ganz wichtiger punkt sehen darf man dabei nicht vergessen
auf gar keinen fall klar werden erneuerbare energien auch derzeit noch gefördert doch
langfristig gesehen steckt ein großer volkswirtschaftlicher nutzen
dahinter und zwar einen nutzen der größer ist als die kosten für ihre förderung denn sie schonen das klima und vermeiden dass kosten für energieimporte
entstehen zudem senkt die einspeisung von erneuerbaren energien den strompreis an der börse
das öko-institut angora energiewende hat eine spannende studie zu der frage gemacht welche kosten bis zur energiewende im jahr
2050 anstehen und zwar auf der einen seite auf der basis von erneuerbaren energien und zum anderen auf der basis fossiler energieträger
das fazit zitat ein stromsystem dass im jahr 2050 nahezu
vollständig auf erneuerbaren energien beruht ist nicht nur klimapolitisch
notwendig und technisch machbar sondern aus der system perspektive auch
kostenseitig attraktiv den berechnungen des forschungsteams zufolge wäre ein stromsystem auf basis erneuerbarer energien
entweder gleich teuer oder sogar günstiger als das system das auf fossilen energieträgern droht 64 milliarden euro
kosten für das gesamte strom system auf basis erneuerbarer energien
gegen etwa
67 milliarden euro für ein fossiles
stromsystem somit würde ein solches
energiewende szenario nicht nur als waffe gegen den klimawandel wirken sondern auch als eine art versicherung gegen das risiko hoher
brennstoff und co2 preise und jetzt wünschen wir mal um auf die im vergleich dazu ja so billige kernenergie
im april diesen jahres ist das war eine studie im auftrag von greenpeace veröffentlicht wurden mit einem
kassenergebnis limbach kann eine rein erneuerbare stromerzeugung bei gleicher versorgungssicherheit
günstiger sein als derzeit geplante kernkraftwerke in mehreren osteuropäischen eu-staaten die kosten für eine megawattstunde
produziert durch erneuerbare energie eher liegen demnach bei etwa 100 euro
aktuelle projekte zu atomkraftwerken liegen dagegen bei
126 euro pro megawattstunde dazu der vorstand von greenpeace energy nils müller
der finanzielle vorsprung der erneuerbaren wird noch größer wenn man
zusätzliche kosten für akw störfälle und die noch nicht eingepreist die lagerung von atommüll
berücksichtigt ja anders für die studie ist der plan von polen tschechien der slowakei und ungarn neue
atomkraftwerke zu bauen denn das ist genau der punkt wie es aussieht werden die kosten der kernkraft nämlich im nachhinein auf die
steuerzahler umgelegt und das wird unglaublich teuer grob geschätzt werden es hier in deutschland mehr als 50 milliarden euro
es gibt sogar schätzungen von mehr als 150 milliarden euro inklusive dem abriss der atommeiler die
stromkonzerne die werden sich mit einem relativ bescheidenen beitrag von rund 25 milliarden euro
daran beteiligen ja das hat niemand erzählt als auf die so billige kernkraft gesetzt wurde mit der energiewende
sinken also auch die kosten
36 prozent des stroms wurden im letzten jahr bereits
umweltfreundlich produziert das ist also auch für unseren
geldbeutel eine gute nachricht wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
dann umgeht ihren die kaputte abo box hier auf youtube
verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir von jedem video und zwar vor allen anderen
ja und das täglich garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten noch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
neuartiges wellenkraftwerk c3 wellenenergie converter 5 mal effektiver bis dann
bleibt dran